But first, we have with us
two local admen
who started their own
T-shirt company.
Tim Cramblin and Sam Duvet,
welcome.
- Thanks for having us
on the show, Nadine.
- We watch you all the time.
- Oh, Thanks. Now--
- Not--not like
in a stalker way
'cause, you know--
not like a person
who's, like, obsessed.
- Chill out.
- Yeah, I know. I'm sorry.
- Don't touch her.
- I won't. It's not--
- Tell us
about the T-shirts.
- Well, it seems like
everywhere you go these days,
you see T-shirts
with Detroit slogans on them.
- Psh, you said it, Tim.
You may be familiar
with "Detroit vs. Everybody."
- Just the best.
- And "Detroit Hustles Harder."
- You can't beat it.
- You sure can't,
which is why
we're proud
to present to you
our very own T-shirt,
"De-two-roit."
- And we'd like to thank
our crew members
Lea and Tommy Pencils
for modeling our "De-two-roit"
T-shirts today.
Uh, take it easy on Tommy.
He's a little nervous.
He's not used to being in front
of the camera for a change.
- Well, I got
to be honest, guys.
I don't get it.
It looks like you put a 2
where the T should be.
- Uh, no, not looks like.
That's what we did.
- Yeah, so now
it's "De-two-roit."
- "De-two-roit."
- But why?
- Well...
- Asking--
- That can best be explained
by a freestyle rap
performed by Lea
and Tommy Pencils.
- Sounds like fun.
Lea, Tommy Pencils,
take it away.
- ♪ If you're in the market
for a cool T-shirt ♪
- Uh...uh...
- Oh, no.
- ♪ If you're in the market
for a cool T-shirt ♪
- Is this live?
- Yes, this is live.
- But on a commercial break.
- Why don't we move on?
- No, he can do it.
- Yeah, lead him in again, Lea.
- ♪ If you're in the market
for a cool T-shirt ♪
- Uh...uh...
- Tommy?
- Oh, oh, oh, oh!
- Oh, no!
- Oh, my goodness.
- [laughs]
Assholes.